[音楽]
[拍手]
ん
えーこんにちは皆さんあの絵が立ってるんですけれども
どんなにものかといいますと外部の研究者です
トーンマーチン表面はウェアラブルコンピューティングという
う献上しています
8ベランダってどれ磨くとまぁ切ることができるといいですね
コンピューターを身に付けから伴うような話です
その日に兄弟残れればですねえうちの研究室の家やすいなんですけれども
jal の真ん中にコンピューター q 違いとか入れます
あのー小沢ですねコンピュータ rq 時代くんじゃんって
影響もちょっとこれを持ってきてますけれどもこれメガネが関根っていうかですね
これ前も完結してますこの中にコンピューター入っていてここにディスプレイがある何
この辺画面ができる
あこんなものがおそらく生活入ってない
あるいは復学の本っていうか全幅の中にコンピュータ埋め込まれていいかなのが
どんどん入ってくるんじゃないかなというふうに思いますんで
8こういう時代ですね一体何が起こるかっていうのを僕ら考え
研究をパック15年くらい会っていうわけなんですけれども
ちょっと待ってねココロスしてきたっ
ちょっとだけ交渉を出したいと思いますけれども例えばこういう本ピューターは我々が
正解に入っていくともう笑えのものが変化していく思うわけですね
で例えばこれ戦略が変わるとか言いますけれどもこれすぐた8時間耐久バイクレース
するか
第一杯有名なマイクで作られます
ここに僕ら3年が入ったよってね
ブーバーを
[音楽]
ブーブー飲泉許可さです
例えば事故が多くの命供給は防衛化していればあればもうすぐ8ページが悪くなるとか
あるいは
大マルチ枚がどこにいる
そんな情報を出して
ブーブーブーブー入れ替えガール公開したらカーテンぬうぱか足売って a これおっ
はらしいセンサー員はプロセス今日だそう
入って face time の視線も商品化されたりしています
なのでこういうふうに大物をこの前限の明る完成
やばいですね例えば演出っていうのがあるのです
これはへとコンピュータ一つを打ちましょうという話なんですけれどもねこれ二つに前
コンピュータんせん
コンピュータためにぜひ
人からフェンダーさんあるんですけれども
何さわっ
[音楽]
ん
ブーバーいらっしゃる思います
けれども五の橋では約7割
さあこういうが出てくるわけですねあるいは
例えば人ともコミュニケーション人と人もコミュニケーションも
があるんじゃないかなと思っていてこれ今からエレベーターのリストができますから
ちょっとよく見てみてください
人が出てきます
ちょっと腹使わせません
このスタッフに4 t ベース部
みなさんわかりません
こっ違う
意味わかりました今お前
クルマ好きのもうすぐに埋め込んでるんですねアバシャイマミー密かな思いますよねっ
n one ん
そしてこの酸味鉄平アミーはからと右撮影にも強い
なんで素朴使いそうな cafe rian 負担って言いましたよね
メーカーの山荘マップスマホスカーフ下山の家族咲いています
ということは言うこれ結構可能ですよ206じゃなくてただが一つた s マグ
グループがついたら後ろの人はそれにすぐ気づいてそれに対してリアクションをとる
ことがある
やはり車つなげこさえていた妻が存在なのでそういう一体我々が出るので作った者会議
に戻すともしてさんコミュニケーションローター
なんていうことが考えであのー提供していています
こういうですね fair love こういうコンピュータのサービスを提供するに
あたって
満足台がよくっていうのがセンサーです
遠藤こういう滝ほども車のれながらもそうなんですけれども
コンピューターがこの人が考えていることがこの人でやろうとしていることっていうの
を読み取ってそれに対していセンターサービス提供する必要があるわけですね
なので日当たりフェンス
[音楽]
ブーブー
なんかちょっとついてますけれどもこれが人の標準をループする狙いです
なのでこれをこの目がのおかげで一日生活していると
例えば今日はこんなとこではなかったありがとうなと思った
そういうように感情の変化を記録しておくことでこれまたないがいろいろできるため
みたいなことを考えながら僕らいろんなセンサーを開発して実際現場に取り使ってい
みたいなことを持って行ってきたんですね
bouvet ちょっとこのままでいいのかあぁ協力猛攻プロ佐藤がちょっ
いきますでその人と代表的なこれも僕らの研究ではあるんですけれども
遠藤はちょっと見ていただきますとも
例えばですね
皆さん
ちょっとイメージでほしいんですけど皆さん母さん起きましたん
ちょっと会長が悪いなぁ
映画コース
ブーブー台を打っ人たちはえーっ対応量をキュッ
でウーでここで釣っヒアロスわああああぬーなので
しんどいかもしれないしもしかしたら気のせいかもしれないいやあり my love
そして別に違いはあり僕は言えないですねでこれで体温計を見て
例えば38度っていう数字を見た瞬間に体調が勝つペリシテ
本当に心拍なっちゃうわけですね
これ皆さんご理解いただけると思いますこういうことよくあるんですよね
なので作業の例えばストレートを調べますあるいは
表情しがありますできますということは
今までストレスなんてわかった今会に出たんですけれども
それを数字出して見せてしまうことによってもしたしたらしい新南端
人間の心に持ち出した場所もあって影響を与えてしまうカウンセラー
いうふうにをんでしょ
でこの展示ではですねいろいろ実験をしてるんですけど
例えばですねひとつのパターンして
本当にもしこの人が38度学科とした時日
この回恩恵が嘘をついたらどうなるかビューを知られます
で本当にただ予算から2の人に対してた4 p の星山頂へ県産黒ですよ
いうふうに通うで言ったとしたらどうなるか
元気あるのですね
これもやばそういうイメージないですかね8僕らは自分は曖昧な感覚よりも対応けど
教えていますなのでゲームになっちゃうし
でこれだけではなくて気持ちの問題で渡ってこの後いろいろ調べました村逆実際実験を
頂いたんですね
どうしても例えば心拍の情報ですね六角して心拍の情報を見ていますでその見ている人
に対してあーしんぱんつっ
っていうふうに星ゼロスましょっ
たそうすると一体どうなったかというと本人の心拍がそれにつられて上がってしまうね
つまりパンに心拍の値という情報を見るだけで自分の心拍がポンポン山端からです
これって c ば簡単に本尊ビル対応を使う多くしております並列の人に対してあなた
がちゃんとたちのが食い続けからお前は上がった人が入ってるん
さあこれでちょっと怖いと思うんですよね
情報提供をデザインするときにこういうこともしかしたら考え
もうも遺骨を取れよ恋コンピューターあります
a コンピューター今目の前に画面がありますって言いましたけれども
カメラのついてですね目で見てるためが例えばこんなになったらしましょう
多い場面がよく出ています
猫にみなさんが見ているスマホのだねとか改良等で
中でストップみたいのがあって iphone がアプリおやつなるような賭けを洗っ
てい
これにこういうもう昔だしてですねで100人ぐらい人集めてここにこれ使って
ちょっと自由に写真トピックよというようなことを言います
そういう実験をやりましたその時にちょっと中で細胞していて
排骨 you do ますが
ちょっとっ
例えばに待ってろカメラんぷりっていうのは左側に米がカメラアプリないとなんです
けれどもこの iphone のズーラですね
今まで食べ物になっていますけれどもちょっと頭がを買えばパターンも配っていました
つまり iphone 形でボム写真で
させようとリングフェス発と iphone がハナム写真でているたちの
iphone がこの写真で言ってる人いますで
これってどうでもいいと思うんですよねせ iphone のツアーなんてば本来動力
にゃんってそんなもない人が影響を受ける場所はない
思うわけなんですけれども実際はもうず顕著で実は食べ物のアイヌで行った人たちは
建物の写真いっぱい撮ってきたんですよ
あるいはカナブ写真出玉のアイコン d た人たちは腹の写真をいっぱい撮ってき
ちゃいます
つまりマーコレーと煮崩れなんですけれども
つまりですねこの号でもいい iphone 野津田らみたいなものでも
上にずっと入っていることによって人の行動って
ポンポンされちゃうね
なので
こういうデザインね本日すごくガールさーんというふうに思います
こういうことがたくさん起こっていたのですね
アレセンサ等ポッから何でももしかしたら便利になるかもしれないと思ったけれども
モンスターしたら結構いろんな問題を今かもしれないなぁと思い味なんです
でところにコンピューター装着するコンピューターですけれども
おそらくですねコンピューターを装着する時代というのは必ずやってきます
いつ勝つか分からないですけれども
絶対叶うでやっていると思いますこれは米木なものが身につけるようになるんですね
なのでそうなるそうなると最初に特にいきましたとおり
嶺南のもとが変化していきます
コミュニケーションの変化したりとかあるいはもうスイッチ分の整体の粉を知ることが
できるような被害額はです
そうなってくると桜
もしかしたらそれによって人が公になる可能性もあるかもしれない
ていることが起こらないようになったんですね
そうするとじゃあ我々はピンサロ次回にしなきゃいけない
不幸になるのではなくて人類が幸せに少なくとも方にならないように
心身への影響を考えたコンピューティングのデザインを知らなきゃいけないという考え
になった
つまりですねられようになりますけれどもウェア run for ピールの研究の
コンピューターの研究なんですけれども我々は社会リってい口に合った来てこう
コンピューターがこのセンサどうやって付き合っていくか
っていう生き方の研究がっていう風にちょっと深く考え方も変わってきます
か新しい here 活動しているんですけども
低緯度心情がティっロスしかーしけど身長カー申請
言わないですね雑魚実際何か何をやっているかと言うと
最後の異物を見せしたように情報を見ることと
でそれによって心身が売ってる営業ですねそれによって何が起こるかというものを3
形式だしていきましょう
再現性のあるような形で主人していきましょうと言うという妙にをし合っています
えっそれができなかったらですね例えば新しいはこういう新しいもあって出てきた時に
その日ヴァイスが
浸水に可能な影響を与えないことを我々は求めることができます
でこの例えばガイドラインとして例えば体温を測るようなセンサーとが本当に恐怖て
使わなきゃいけない情報を見せるときにはこういう見せ方をしないと
をしだしたら体がコントロールされてしまうはしれないよそういう風な感じで
大画面を停止することによって悪いことが起こらないです
動かない
そうすることによって
いわゆるこの新しいものですね新しいもやんであるとか新しいものが出てきたときに
それのネガティブな部分を8校
出てこないある髪をしないようにしていいところだけ
いたしていきましょう
いうことがわからないんですね
まあこういうことをやってい
でたとえパリ線埼京の情報提示で122がコントロールされるんだなぁずも
をして待つ大学いっぱいあって例えばこれはありま
メンタルスポーツてしかも今行くよんどこに取り組みしているんですけれども
情報提示メンタルスポーツ成績を上げることができます例えばターンすって
ダーツを投げてそれに対して反公開します
でダート投げてもしうまく投げるから販売がある
女簡単ですねって失敗したのでお山
ヒペリオンマン4強をちょっと練習したとします
そうするとパブロフの維新ではプレビューパブロフの犬同じなんですけれども
もう成功とファンファーレ失敗ことだというのが学習されてしまう
でじゃあ follow 柄が何をするかと言うと今度はですね
本番の時本番で投擲するときに
[音楽]
慣れる前サビファンファルっていきます
つまり作業順番は投げて良かったらも悪かったんですけれどもそれを繰り返し学習する
ことによって投げる前にファンファーレとですねもう成功しているわけです
お歳暮してるんでそっから投げたらスコアあーおち冊あります
っていうことがわからん
ということはこういう情報提示の天狗の子業務艇の理論を使えばいろんなウィンパル
スポーツ持って気があるスコアが日本のチームもスコラですね上る可能性があるわけ
ですね
こういうふうにうまく使えば非常にいいところがあるのでうまく使っていきたいなと
いうふうに思っています
で
ここまでお話してても皆さん
言いたいことはですね
実はなんだったということですけれどもこういう新しいものっていうのはこれからも
言語
できますこれで荒ぶるコンピュータこんな女の9画面が出る
言われた部分にさあ皆さんこういうイメージをお答えましたか
あるいは今なんて食べ ai の兼ね合いが白鋼科学の話もよくできてますけれども何
か新しい
なりますのでそこには今日悪いいいところと悪いところ3くらい紹介したつもりなん
ですけどもほとんど新しい ponta 良い部分と悪いというのが存在しているわけ
ん
ただ
えっとその物事に対してですね悪い
ですけれどは実はすごく簡単なんですねああこういうものがあるときにいえこんなもの
をつけたら目が悪くなるんじゃないのとかこんなものをつけたらコンピュータと記事名
が気がするじゃないのかとかあるいはなーんとなく試合
悪口言う発明簡単なんですよね
でだいたいそこで思考停止したの人が多いです何となくイメージが悪いのか混乱やな
ところに寝るから
これは良くない
って言ってヒールセンター星野が多いです
批評家みたいな人か子ばっかになって a
しまうわけですねところがこの一行下の一夏ばったりでは世界を回らないわけです
クリエーションする人で違う世界に回していくわけですから皆さんね
その後も悪い部分を見つける坊様に良い部門
タンクっていいんす
[音楽]
ブーブーちょっとあっ位以下新しい一愛していい部分
持っ同時に入っやっていきましょうそれに対して林光やっていきましょう
っていうことをブーブー推進する立場なんですけども
a 情報もある以上も真面目に出していきますのでそれを
まぁみろ歳
これは一体どういうものなのかっていうのに対してそれでいろいろ加工面そう言って
ほしいあれは使ってます
あるいは使わがいるようなんなん
思って
a 今から以上ありがとう2